the house select committee investigating
the january 6 attack is promising to
show americans never before seen
evidence of the most violent assault on
the capitol in more than 200 years it
starts with a prime time hearing
thursday night about the effort by
former president trump's supporters to
stop president biden from succeeding him
scott mcfarland is on capitol hill for
us scott good morning hey tony good
morning the house select january 6
committee has conducted nearly a
thousand interviews and collected nearly
140 000 records but this week they're
searching for something else
an audience for their work
an assault unlike any in american
history has led to an investigation
unlike any other
now the findings will be presented in
prime time the public hasn't seen it
woven together how one thing led to
another how one line of effort to
overturn the election led to another a
special committee of seven democrats and
two republicans have held a series of
high-profile interviews and depositions
with key members of former president
trump's inner circle members of his
family
even accused rioters themselves
including those charged with conspiring
to violently attack in others of
conspiring to orchestrate the riots in
recent court filings the committee has
shown some of its cards stating it has
enough evidence to believe that trump
conspired to defraud the u.s
congresswoman liz chaney vice chair of
the committee spoke to it on cbs sunday
morning was it a conspiracy i think
certainly i mean look if you you look at
the court filings
do you believe it was a conspiracy i do
republicans have largely boycotted the
panel after also blocking plans for an
independent commission including leader
kevin mccarthy one of five house
republicans who also defied committee
subpoenas seeking interviews about what
donald trump knew and when so is this
really a legitimate committee or is this
a political committee going after their
opponents but capitol police officer
harry dunn who helped defend the capitol
january 6 says there is more at stake i
want justice i want accountability and i
want justice for what me and my
co-workers went through a big hurdle
capturing america's attention right now
video presentations and witness
testimony are expected at these hearings
all of which will be conducted in june
one member of the committee tells me
though the investigation and the
interviews will continue
even after the hearings begin
tony
all right scott got it thank you